so Israel is currently fighting on two
fronts for eight days it has pounded the
Gaza Strip dropping thousands of bombs
on the already besed onclave and now
confrontations have escalated on its
northern border with Lebanon at least
one Israeli has been killed and three
wounded after Hezbollah said that it
targeted a military post near the border
in a missile attack in response the
Israeli Army has shelled lebanon's
border and set up a 4 km long buffer
zone aliash joins us live from AA asab
in Lebanon Ali run us through what
happened this
morning well uh civil this morning
Hezbollah announced that its forces
launched a missile attack on a military
Post in the area of sha uh what you
understood is that one Israeli was
killed and several were injured then the
Israel forces started retaliating
hitting and founding the borders between
Lebanon and Israel following that hisbah
attacked this post just the one that you
can see in the camera right now maybe
our colleague Riot could show us this is
AR rahib or the monk uh military
position it was hit on several uh with
several guided missiles then Israel
retaliated once again at this
Village and other villages in the
surrounding hasah retaliated once again
so I mean there were a lot of tit for
tats today and this is just part of this
whole context but let me just mention
this thing over the past eight seven
days it's been a week since Lebanon got
into this situation we have around 13
people killed uh five hisbah Fighters
two from the Islamic Jihad three from
Hamas um couple of elderly yesterday in
sheah farms and our colleague is
Abdullah from Reuters so we have this
number of uh casualties now there are
some Fighters and there are three
civilians so the casualty the number of
casualties is raising the issue is that
many are very concerned that this could
go out of control given the fact that
the human price is increasing day after
day and the activities on the border are
also increasing day after day yeah Ellie
look you've done a great job over the
last few days of explaining to our
viewers that these exchanges of
artillery uh gunfire missiles Rockets
Etc between Hezbollah and Israel can be
read as messaging as signaling from both
sides depending on you know the type of
Weaponry they use the targets especially
that they that they're targeting what
kind of an escalation within this
military dialogue what kind of
escalation does this
represent well clearly there is a kind
of a pattern going on now for example
this attack the attack on this post or
on this area is a retaliation when
hisbah is initiating attacks it's
initiating in the Shabba Farms the the
area that's uh disputed and the one that
the Lebanese government regards as a
Lebanese territory so hisbah will
initiate over there when hisbah is
retaliating then they're retaliating on
the blue line in the areas that aren
disputed on Israeli territories at the
same time we have another factor which
is the Palestinian factions Hamas and
Jihad the alasan brigades and the C
brigades whenever they whenever they are
attacking when well they are being they
have the facilitation from hasah is
facilitating their moves logistically
and of course being in this area can't
happen without he's
conent Ali Hashem reporting from
Southern Lebanon near the Israeli
Lebanon border thank you very much Ali